when marty went to steve's house to look
at the script for three amigos
marty you walked in and you looked at
steve's paintings and his beautiful home
and you said gee
i never realized you were this rich
because i've seen your work
and it was an immediate like
is that true that you started putting
down steve it is immediately absolutely
true and
because truthfully i was amazed i was
looking at all this and
we had never met and you immediately
laughed i remember i immediately laughed
and then when we were doing by but i
still didn't uh
uh you know get to see him a lot and
then on the set i was remember walking
to the set the first day
and i'm walking with chevy and we're
dressed up like amigos
and from behind me
yeah i heard
marty
as catherine hepburn and what was the
exact line i wish i brought my bicycle
it was such an off-the-wall line
can you guys believe the incredible
uh success of three amigos now but it
really you know it was a modest uh
success well you know what happened was
we released three amigos and you know i
had my heart into it i don't know what
you had but
i was a writer i whatever
kind of my idea
and then it comes out and it does fine
and i'd go see it in a theater and you
know with the full audit you want to see
how it plays you know it played okay
and then
i get a call
and it's empire magazine in england
which is a big uh movie magazine and
they said we want to put you marty and
chevy on the cover of our magazine i
said why
they said well it's the 25th anniversary
of three amigos and i said
so and they explained that it was sort
of this cult thing now or hit or or you
know parents watch it with their kids
you know i mean i already always had a
sense of it because i would you know do
a lot of shows and be in a lot of
airports
and you can always kind of tell when
people come up to you what they're going
to talk about and if it was like
yeah if it's
you know uh if they're dressed like an
amigo
no no no but i mean if
if if the guy is 28 and looks like he's
been like kind of drugged for about
eight years they're going to talk about
clifford
and if they but it but usually a 40 year
old guy would come up and he'd talk
about three mingles i get things like
saying i you know i watched that with my
dad it was a bonding moment with mike
right